the girag and experience what the fuck
man we're weird so weird
what a stupid culture well you know I
can't stop thinking about the guy that
farted at the sink the airport we talked
about it for 10 minutes afterwards dudes
fart when they pee go to the bathroom
dudes constantly farting in public
restrooms yeah but we were at the sink
and the dude was washing his hands and
he caught a monster fart and I told
Tommy about it I was like dude this guy
he broke he broke the rules yeah I
walked out just before this happened I
unfortunately missed the incident but
you said it immediately and I was I kept
wrapping my head around I think what
I've come to the conclusion is that if
you do that all I'm looking for is for
you to acknowledge it yeah yeah you need
to say something yeah I want you to say
something about that because I was
thinking about how an old guy one time
farted next to me in like on a tram on
it and then the airport and I was like
jeez he let it fucking pretty big fart
and I looked at him he goes snuck out of
me I was like alright and I kind of took
away like no what were you betting in it
yes yeah I was like well thank you for
acknowledging your your fart right now
yeah this guy was just washing his hands
and just the sink is not the urine I
don't think yeah I had a pastor yeah it
was definitely urinal who does that it
was definitely a gray area it's
definitely great yeah people fart all
the time at the urinals that's so common
yeah I hear a lot of farty but if you
get done zip up walk all the way around
and wash your hands in the middle
washing at you just unload and no one
said a word
everyone just it just let it go and then
we got outside I was like you know dude
how do you feel about this yeah I can't
stop thinking about and then we're
trying to figure out what kind of farts
girls cut when they're in the bathroom
and whether or not they wash their hands
before on each other probably not as
much not as much but they definitely
drop heat in there once they close that
door or then they allow themselves yeah
they allow themselves to fucking fart it
up mmm you know you know they really let
them rip yeah once they get in that door
they close that door they just ah you
have to if you're taking a shit yeah you
gotta fart
but I wonder if they fart whether
washing their hands these are the things
I think yeah absolutely
I wonder about what we need more of this
in the world do you mask your farts when
you should shit in a public restroom no
let it out God do what you we didn't
hold up to the Caliph girl farts yeah I
did Jesus Christ you have that on your
phone yeah I love girl farts yeah 40
year old man's got that on his phone
Christ a huge fetish now it's actually a
websit is it's amazing always been yeah
it's amazing there's been fart porn
forever where dudes like sniff farts
whatever girl's ass yeah I am fat
naughty
we played some fart clips on our show
and we're talking about it and the guy
wrote in and he was like a big-time fart
fetish and we like what like what's the
thinking about and he was like I think
it's just back to the taboo of it that
the pretty girl is not supposed to so
he's uh you know I mean like that it's
yeah this should be on a dirty girl yes
and yeah he loves you know pretty girl
doing it is like like the ultimate thing
yeah that's the thing about people's
like they want people to be naughty
right just cuz we feel so most people at
least feel so confined by the rules and
I think women so even more so than men
women even more so than men because you
know society wants you to be a lady in a
certain way sure you know and there's
slut-shaming you know love to be a slut
you not allowed to do what you want to
do you know like if a woman wants to go
out and fuck a bunch of different guys
like if woman wants to fuck two guys in
a night she's a terrible person like if
you find out about that oh my god she
she went to this guy's house she fucked
him then she left and she went to this
other guy's house I fucked him what a
horn a tional champion like girls be
like what a whore yeah but if you told
me so he decides he leaves his this
girl's house and it's like you know what
fuck I can call somebody else he called
somebody else and he goes and fucks her
and we're like that's great the guy's an
animal
yeah it was it wasn't even done yeah I
wanted to fuck more that's not easy that
is crazy though that we don't you know
that we have that that double standard
for that I mean I remember in college a
guy and friend going into a sorority
house and banging girls in the same
house in the same night in different
rooms and like yeah we all were like
that's fantastic you're such a hero like
yours
we were also happy with his story but if
a girl went to a fraternity house fuck
one guy says goodnight honey left and
then knocked on a door hit Comanches
fucking on dirty bitch fucking whore
yeah and I really should have brought
her yeah I mean well or not you know
either way we should let her do whatever
she wants to do yeah she's just fucking
people
why do you what do you care were they
gonna stay together forever they're in
college Jesus Christ know if you ever
probably the girl fucks one guy then
fucks another guy that night you're
silly yeah you are what's wrong could be
one of those guys yeah she's all you
gotta do is throw your dick in front of
her obviously she likes them so that
suppression leads to like a reaction is
just holding back leads to this need to
let it go
yeah and the girl just farts right in
that dude's face guys like I can't
believe you did you dirty bitch I'm
dirty farting - I'm a farty bitch park
my mouth again
that's so funny the people that own this
isle of girl frets are actually watching
right now about that so stupid oh my
gosh that's not gonna leak yeah I'm a
bad girl okay but it it the smell and
the fucking noise and the whole thing
the naughtiness of it all we held it in
Boston girls farting we have a thing
about about people shitting - you know
like no one wants to admit they just
took a shit we want to hide in
ya're it up with noise and fans we want
to light matches and yeah it is weird I
mean I I don't like the single single
stall unisex bathrooms yeah when you got
a shit shit and then there's like
someone's like you're going in there and
you're like ah fuck man why don't you go
in first
not only gonna shit out of a shoe I know
I get but you get that you know like I
feel like I can't relax or you can say
can I please use the restroom like if
you're at a meeting if you're having a
meeting or something like that say I'll
be right back after you restroom but you
can't say look I got a shit I can't keep
talking to guys I got to take a shit you
say I use a restroom it's ambiguous okay
go ahead
yeah and you leave you know you can't
say I'm so sorry I was late for this
meeting I got here on time but I had to
shit
Yeah right right you can't say that they
gotta be upset you got to go to the
restroom and then you know that the
clocks running
so cuz if you come back 15 minutes later
and covered in sweat they're like wow
you take a monster shit huh you can't
really get that out there you gotta
fucking I gotta grind this thing up and
sometimes that's what you have to do
sometimes you have to take a 10 minute
heater yeah like sometimes you just you
take a shit it comes out clump clump and
you're like ah there's a lot more up
there yeah damn it happen on the flight
yesterday oh no as soon as I sat down I
was one of it when we go to sleep and I
was like I got to take a shit and it was
during takeoff so then you're like
waiting for it to hit 10,000 feet you
know and then you're waiting for them to
turn the seatbelt sign off and I go in
there like this is gonna be this is like
a fucking marathon shit but I didn't
have time for it so I really dropped
half of it off just like fall asleep
oh no yeah and then Leon I finished it
was it's pretty pretty dramatic it's one
of the weird things about your body is
that there's like this intangible sense
of how much shit is in there yeah you
know like when you're taking a shit like
you have the feeling that weird feeling
like I smell shit or I feel shit brewing
my fill of shit cooking in the oven yeah
and then once you're taking that shit
you got this pressure thing like you
know it's in there know what's up there
and there's a certain amount like god
damn this isn't ready this is a diet
yeah alright I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to umph to empty it in and I'm to
come back later yeah and that's and
that's the worst you like when it's all
gone yeah certain foods too will trigger
just amazing amounts of shit that come
out of you where you're just like is my
body mostly shit you're like am I just a
walking talking shit machine because
sometimes I like the amount that will
come out of me is just incredible to me
and I cannot get over what's coming out
of me if you think about how much food
you eat though if you sink think of like
your entire day if you shit once a day
thinking about breakfast in there and
then lunch in there and then your dinner
in there like this giant mound of food
that goes in your body and then snack
like you might have a protein bar along
the way and then you'll have all this
you drink thing you might drink milk
which has got some solids in there and
then slowly but surely compress that and
to just
or big ropey shit logs it's amazing it's
not really bigger now picture a pretty
girls go out and over your face and
letting it all over you hmm well that's
a glass-like all right big thing people
guys copy Tim guys like women shitting
on class coffee tables yeah then we
always heard about Stallone those was
like one of those rumors probably made
up it's probably the Richard Gere gerbil
thing yeah someone decided to say it and
then it sounds cool so people repeat it
yeah it was Stallone likes to get into
tables and girls take big juicy shits on
those tables he loves him cuz he want to
fuck him just wants him to shit I'd like
to watch people shit it's over a glass
table just to see it come out maybe once
yeah sure what about I got like Joey
Diaz natural I think that's the one that
would be at the top of my list what if
he fell and land on a table a table
shattered and you died or glass went
through your neck shit was in your
eyeballs and you died knowing that shit
was all of your face and feeling the hot
blood rush out of your neck Wow
that's our dog's art I slipped whoops
add too much sodium I think that it
would be much more interesting to watch
Diaz shit than some model I'd like to
see him have explosive diarrhea on a
glass table well I would like to see a
girl who's like addicted to stimulants
like who's trying to be really skinny
how just how little she actually shifts
into there my air comes out probably
shocking see like little tiny poops
curly squirrel eaters yeah the slightly
bile the yellow smell to it what's going
on Jim sorry that's what they want
anything just half of her shit is pills
Oh
how does Devil's come out yeah like non
dissolved pills English clumps yeah but
I mean it would be fun to watch a couple
times maybe watch I don't know about fun
but maybe fascinating I think as an art
exhibit we talk about art Allah this
weekend it'd be great to set up a live
exhibit I've always thought of this
where you have like 10 people 50 feet up
and they're butt-naked and they've
different body types and they're sitting
on glass toilets with glass tubes coming
down and then the exhibit is you walk
around and they all shit
like that'd be kind of fun and they
flush it and you see these glass tubes
fill up with shit and come tumbling down
yeah and then usual a septic at the
bottom a giant large tank filled with
shit that's all glass and you have
different colored hair and you're like I
this is my creation I this is if you
wanted to buy this it's 5:15
[Music]